[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission pour bien démarrer la
soirée dans les Yvelines avec au
programme de l'actualité des infos
pratiques et des idées de sortie voici
le programme de ce 10 janvier
tout au long du mois de janvier période
traditionnelle des vœux TV 78 reçoit les
maires de 50 ans en Yvelines pour parler
des grands projets de l'année 2023 dans
leur ville ce soir focus sur Coignières
sobriété énergétique et d'autres sujets
également à quoi faut-il s'attendre le
maire de la commune Didier Fisher sera
notre invité c'est une nouvelle rubrique
dans le 7 8 le tour d'horizon des
informations insolites du département
sapin de Noël recyclé de manière
originale sauvetage et défend notre
sélection à suivre et puis la culture
avec le temps des humains ce spectacle
se veut interactif et avant-gardiste une
plongée dans le futur dans l'année 2020
proposés par la compagnie Pixum c'est
jusqu'au 15 janvier au Petit Moulin et
des veaux de Cernay
et ce sera donc en deuxième partie
d'émission dans notre partie dédiée à la
culture alors il y aura également des
invités dans cette émission pour les
amateurs de photos un rendez-vous et
proposé par l'association Villepreux
images pixels c'est une exposition qui
se tient et du 14 au 22 janvier à la
maison Saint-Vincent stavillepreux plus
d'une vingtaine de photographes se
présente présente leur cliché alors pour
en parler on aura Gilles fait qui est
déjà avec nous en plateau bonsoir alors
vous êtes photographe merci d'être avec
nous également responsable de la
communication de ville prémageux pixels
en quelques mots l'association c'est
quoi alors c'est une association de la
de la ville de Villepreux qui a été créé
en 2008 et donc on réunit des passionnés
de la photo et on échange et ont bien
sûr on forme les gens à la photographie
mais c'est avant tout une progression
par l'échange et il faut que ça soit des
passionnés quoi voilà et dans un sens on
parlera donc de cette exposition qui se
tient donc à Villepreux à vos côtés
Didier Fischer merde gauche de
Coignières bonsoir bonsoir et bonne
année bonne année bonne année meilleurs
vœux à tous autour de la table alors
justement janvier c'est la période des
vœux vous allez présenter les vôtres au
coin et rien ce samedi au salon Antoine
de Saint-Exupéry ce sera à 16h30 et 21
janvier ça sera le 21 janvier j'ai dit
oui ça sera samedi prochain samedi
prochain ce sera samedi prochain je vous
l'ai déjà être à la fin du mois de
janvier voilà ce sera donc le 21 janvier
vous avez 16h30 vous allez donc les
avancer à 16h30 vous les avez avancés
dans une nouvelle formule qui est dédiée
à la sobriété énergétique on peut le
dire un peu plus sobre oui un peu plus
hop des vœux un peu plus sobre on était
en 2000-2020 c'est le dernier année où
on a pu effectivement en janvier 2020
faire nos vœux la population en 2020 on
était sur 30000 euros à peu près de vœux
vœux à la population et veut au
personnel aujourd'hui on sera sur 15000
vous voyez on divise par deux la facture
mais c'est important quand même de
retrouver les Coignières
à côté tout à fait c'est important en
effet c'est un moment de convivialité
c'est un moment d'échange souvent et
c'est vraiment vraiment je pense
nécessaire aujourd'hui et la population
réclame justement ces moments-là on va
voir avec vous quelles sont les grands
projets de l'année 2023 dans la commune
également l'équipe de TV 78 à cette
table également Michael el midoro
bonsoir vous allez nous présenter dans
un instant les informations du jour en
deux mots l'actualité vinoise du jour on
va parler du nombre de verbalisations
sur le stationnement payant à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye qui a augmenté en
2022 on parlera également d'une
signature à Voisins le bretonneux une
signature d'un contrat d'aménagement
régional avec la région Île-de-France
donc c'est à suivre dans un instant et
puis j'en parlais dans les titres c'est
une nouvelle séquence dans le 7 8 les
informations insolites avec vous
Véronique Ithurbide bonsoir
on a l'habitude de vous voir sur TV 78
dans l'émission Vy P qui est dédié à aux
personnalités du territoire yvelinois et
là vous venez donc avec une nouvelle
chronique les insoumis de Véronique
c'est le nom de cette séquence voilà
donc c'est des petites infos que j'ai
glanées ici et là et qui m'ont fait
sourire ou pas ou qui sont importantes à
divulguer voilà de tous les domaines
gastronomie culture animale animal
animaux
avec
le zoo Thoiry et les cadeaux fait au
faux et autres bestioles vous avez après
le sauvetage des fonds ça c'est une
histoire assez atroce mais qui se
termine bien donc j'encourage les gens à
s'accrocher rester jusqu'au bout et
après on parlera de la gastronomie avec
un nouveau resto qui s'ouvre sous les
halles de Versailles et après culture
avec Tim DUP un chanteur compositeur
auteur producteur absolue génial qui
fait un concert pour l'association
Laurette Fugain et donc on parle de tout
ça dans un instant alors
direction aussi Marnes-la-Coquette dans
ce 7 8 ou ce soir les départements des
Yvelines et des Hauts-de-Seine présente
leurs vœux on fera aussi le bilan du CES
de Las Vegas dans cette édition avec une
entreprise divinoise qui était présente
à cette grand-messe mondiale des
technologies et puis comme tous les
mardis à la Suisse l'astuce du chef pour
briller en cuisine et ce soir c'est le
chef
tomorroido du restaurant étoilé le
village de Marly-le-Roi qui se prêtent
au jeu mais avant tout cela place à la
météo de demain
et le retour peut-être demain de
quelques rayons de soleil même si il
faudra les apercevoir derrière les
nuages quelques gouttes de pluie
pourraient même tomber dans les environs
de Versailles côté température compter à
10 degrés dans la cité royale et
Mantes-la-Jolie 9 degrés à Houdan et
Rambouillet dans l'après-midi plus de
pluie a priori il devrait faire 10
degrés dans la partie centrée sud des
Yvelines 11 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et
ce mercredi 11 janvier nous fêterons les
poulains
les informations du jour avec vous
Michael et on commence par le chiffre du
jour
59430 c'est le nombre de verbalisations
sur le stationnement payant à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye en 2022 un record
pour la commune qui a effectué
376 741 contrôlent sur un an là aussi un
record d'après les élus et contrôle sont
surtout menés dans l'hypercentre
l'objectif dans cette zone est d'assurer
une rotation rapide pour permettre aux
clients des 600 commerces d'accéder au
stationnement il y a donc eu 100 000
contrôles de plus en 2022 et donc plus
de verbalisation on écoute les réactions
des automobilistes et des piétons micro
de Patrick Jacques de Dixmude alors ça
me dérangerait pas s'il y avait
suffisamment de place pour tout le monde
faire des contrôles ça me paraît ça me
paraît logique payer sa place ça me
paraît logique mais autant faut-il qu'il
y en ait pour tout le monde au top VTC
je paye trois amende par mois de
stationnement et des fois je suis dans
la voiture et j'ai fait déjà des
contestations qui ne sont pas acceptés
oui je me suis fait pruner deux fois
pour une minute de retard voilà
bah c'est comme à Paris en fait tout
comme à Paris non c'est pas normal non
il vous aligne c'est quand même quelque
chose oui je suis un habitué des
contrats oui il y a des chances oui
je l'ai pas bien sûr je les paye bah tu
vois à chaque fois c'est majoré alors on
est bien obligé de les payer
et vous Grégory est-ce que vous êtes un
habitué des contraventions par semaine
déjà arrivé avec TV 78 il faut être très
vigilant sur l'ensemble des
verbalisations 25% sont délivrés à des
Saint-Germain nois et 75% des personnes
vivant en dehors de la commune on prend
à présent la direction de carrière sous
Poissy après à 12 mois de travaux la
réhabilitation extension de l'école
élémentaire et maternelle Jean Gino est
désormais terminé la nouvelle école est
composée à 70% de bois pour répondre aux
nouveaux enjeux environnementaux
l'établissement permettra un nombre de
classes plus importants 25 contre 15
auparavant il y aura aussi un espace
périscolaire de 200 mètres carrés
permettant d'accueillir les enfants le
matin le midi et le soir ce projet était
en partie financé par le département à
des Yvelines à hauteur de 5,9 millions
d'euros 70% du coup de l'équipement on
en parlera sûrement avec la mère de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux Alexandre Rosetti
quand elle viendra sur ce plateau si tu
ne signature dont on parle à présent qui
va aider à la réalisation de nombreux
projets dans la ville ce lundi 9 janvier
la ville a signé un contrat
d'aménagement régional avec la région
Île-de-France la commune a reçu le
maximum de la dotation un million
d'euros qui vont servir à plusieurs
opérations dont l'aménagement d'un
nouveau cimetière il y aura aussi
d'autres projets comme les voiries ou
l'isolation de la verrière du centre
sportif des pyramides on écoute la
réaction de la mère de la commune au
micro de TV 78 c'est considérable voilà
c'est une c'est une très belle aide
d'autant plus qu'elle vient s'ajouter à
d'autres aides que nous avons eu par le
passé également par la région
nous avons vraiment la chance d'être
entouré et par la région et par le
département des Yvelines qui chacun font
des contrats avec les communes et
finance
de façon assez importante nos projets
structurants
un cas de grippe aviaire découvert à
Versailles la ville de Versailles placée
en zone de contrôle temporaire après la
découverte d'un cas de grippe aviaire
sur une buse dans ce contexte les
détenteurs de poules volaille ou oiseaux
dans le monde doivent renseigner un
formulaire en ligne à la mairie ils
doivent mettre à l'abri les volatiles à
réaliser à des surveillances
quotidiennes des animaux et surtout
signaler toute mortalité animale à son
vétérinaire à Mantes-la-Jolie des
youtubeurs ont fait la polémique ils ont
organisé un koh-lanthèse un Koh-Lanta
des cités ce dimanche à Mantes-la-Jolie
on va voir les images le tournage était
organisé par des vidéastes du
Val-de-Marne le principe organisé une
parodie du jeu télévisé Koh-Lanta avec
différentes épreuves au programme partie
de football en voiture avec un gros
ballon un sprint avec une combinaison
rembourrée avec un chien lâché sur les
participants le problème c'est que cette
manifestation était non déclarée donc
illégal la mairie a annoncé qu'elle va
t’époser plein de contre X pour
occupation illégale du domaine public
les organisateurs avaient fait polémique
dernièrement avec un épisode enregistré
à la maison d'arrêt de Fresnes en
juillet dernier la vidéo à
Mantes-la-Jolie devrait être diffusé à
cette semaine enfin pour terminer alors
vous précédez un peu Véronique vous
allez nous parler d'une information
insolite la formation insolite tout à
fait elle concerne un joueur de l'équipe
de France qui a été en partie formé dans
les Yvelines à Clairefontaine et qui a
marqué trois buts en finale de la
dernière Coupe du Monde vous voyez de
qui je veux parler de table quelqu'un
qui a marqué un triplet en finale de
Coupe du Monde un français un Français
gif fait bah exactement
une star planétaire on sait tous
humiliatisation qui a aussi touché le
Pérou cette année en 2022 230 bébés ont
été prénommés Mbappé par leurs parents
et notamment pendant ou après la Coupe
du monde les Péruviens sont apparemment
friands de nom sur l'actualité il y a eu
267 Messi 176 Argentina le prénom
Antoine Griezmann a été donné à 86
enfants du côté des filles 551
ont été baptisés Rennes Elisabeth et ce
que vous pourriez appeler votre fils à
Mbappe Grégory pas vraiment mais je sais
que après la Coupe du Monde 98 il y a eu
même phénomène pour Zinédine Zidane il y
avait quelque chose alors c'est au Pérou
mais c'était en France et je crois même
dans le monde entier et oui ça arrive
souvent des inédits Didier Fisher le
confirme merci Michael pour toutes ces
informations vous vous l'appelleriez
Zinédine Zidane
Mbappé peut-être un peu moins mais
Zidane pourquoi pas merci Michael et si
vous aussi près de chez vous vous êtes
témoin d'un fait d'une information qui
vous fait réagir n'hésitez pas à le dire
sur les réseaux sociaux en partageant
avec le hashtag à 7 8 news
[Musique]
l'information du jour au niveau national
c'est la réforme des retraites le
gouvernement a dévoilé le contour les
contours du texte et ce depuis 17h avec
une présentation qui est prévue devant
le Conseil des ministres désormais le 23
janvier le projet de loi doit être
examiné examiné en commission à
l'Assemblée nationale à partir du 30
janvier et dans l'hémicycle à partir du
6 février alors ce qu'il faut retenir
des annonces et que le gouvernement
accélère sur le sujet l'âge légal du
départ atteindra à 64 ans à partir de
2030 et 1200 euros brut de pension
minimale par mois pour les nouveaux
retraités enfin une dernière annonce
c'est la durée de cotisation qui est
reportée à 43 annuités et ce
progressivement jusqu'en 2027 alors dans
l'émission PAF ce matin sur TV 78
Patrice karmouz et ses invités ont
évoqué le sujet avec notamment l'ancien
député macroniste des Yvelines Didier
bécher qui explique pourquoi selon lui
la réforme est nécessaire regardez le
budget social en France c'est 800
milliards
d'accord donc c'est le plus la plus
grosse dépense donc c'est la plus grosse
dépense de l'État et c'est le pays la
France au monde qui dépense le plus dans
le social donc quand on dit le social
c'est la branche famille la sécurité
sociale et les retraites les retraites
dans ces 800 milliards pèsent pour plus
de la moitié 15% du PIB donc on voit
déjà que dans notre budget social quand
on commence à parler on parle beaucoup
en ce moment de la situation de la santé
de la revalorisation du personnel de
santé donc on voit bien que ça s'inscrit
dans un contexte qui est compliqué et je
le dis comme ça rapidement parce que
j'avais souvent l'habitude de dire ça le
budget de l'État c'est un camembert à
portion construite connue et qui
n'évolue pas c'est pas une entreprise
l'état on va pas faire des parts de
marché supplémentaires vendre des trucs
en plus donc si on donne à un moment
donné beaucoup plus sur le secteur de la
santé ou c'est le secteur de la famille
il faut que la branche retraite qui pèse
lourd soit équilibrée
vous disiez en introduction oui
finalement le déficit est pas peut-être
pas si important etc moi c'est pareil
c'est en plus l'équation est très simple
en 12 milliards
12 milliards je crois partir de 2027
dans le dans le corps donc 12 milliards
chaque année pas uniquement 12 milliards
c'est 12 milliards chaque année 12
milliards ça représente exactement c'est
le même chiffre de ce qui était dépensé
pour le Ségur de la santé donc pour
financer en 2020 en 2021 et en 2022
l'augmentation des personnels de santé
donc a été négocié avec les syndicats du
secteur de la santé au moment du Ségur
ça coûte 12 milliards donc on voit bien
que on peut pas s'asseoir si on veut
avoir une protection supplémentaire si
on veut 1200 euros de pension minimale
pour l'ensemble des personnes qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie il faut le
financer donc on peut pas se permettre
de perdre 12 milliards et puis un
système par répartition par définition
il doit être équilibré sinon on bascule
en solidarité nationale c'est à dire que
c'est l'impôt qui finalement va payer le
déficit ça devient très bancal et on va
revenir à des discussions est-ce qu'il
faut pas mettre du privé dedans etc
l'exécutif pour justifier ce projet de
réforme c'est et bien de d'équilibrer un
système qui sera déficitaire aussi
freiner les dépenses publiques l'homme
de gauche que vous êtes que comment
réagit-il à ce projet de réforme jusqu'à
preuve du contraire aujourd'hui il est
équilibré il est excédentaire il sera
difficile à partir de enfin il le sera à
partir l'année prochaine et un petit peu
plus jusqu'en 2030 jusqu'à 12 milliards
je crois de ce que disait Didier Becher
bon aujourd'hui je ne vois pas l'urgence
qu'il y a justement intervenir en plus
un certain nombre d'économistes nous
disent très clairement qu'une petite
augmentation finalement des cotisations
suffirait à combler ce déficit et
revenir à l'excédent donc je crois qu'il
y a d'autres raisons qui poussent à mon
sens le gouvernement
financer d'autres projets bien entendu
peut-être dans le domaine social mais
d'autres projets que celui des retraites
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas péril dans la
demeure et comment vous réagissez au
premier annonces je disais tout à
l'heure là je légale qui a atteindra 64
ans en 2030 alors une autre annonce que
je n'avais pas dit c'est que l'âge de
décote est maintenu ainsi à 67 ans on
n'a pas les 72 trimestres
heureusement heureusement quand même
mais aller jusqu'à 64 ans c'était une
chose pour un certain nombre de
professions c'est peut-être pas un gros
problème mais il faut pas quand même
oublier aujourd'hui qu'en France vous
avez un quart des plus pauvres qui
meurent avant d'atteindre la retraite
avant 62 ans vous avez aussi en ce qui
concerne les travailleurs entre
guillemets ceux qui aujourd'hui
attendent leur retraite à l'âge de aller
je dirais un an avant la retraite
beaucoup ne sont déjà plus dans le
travail ils sont au chômage ils sont en
maladie ces gens-là et bien ils seront
encore un peu plus précarisés avec ce
système c'est pour ça je pense pense que
là il n'est pas aussi juste que cela
d'aller jusqu'à 64 ans et d'augmenter de
cette façon là la durée des cotisations
d'ailleurs le porte-parole du
gouvernement Olivier Vérand sera demain
à Coignières il va rentrer
je l'accueillerai
aussi on en parlera probablement mais il
y a beaucoup de salariés qui sont
effectivement hostiles aujourd'hui à
cette réforme des retraites et
d'ailleurs je crois que la majorité des
français n'est pas pour alors avant de
passer à la suite et de parler des
projets 2023 à Coignières nous allons
prendre la direction de
Marnes-la-Coquette dans le département
des Hauts-de-Seine c'est à limitrophe du
département des Yvelines puisque
l'établissement public
interdépartemental Yvelines notre Seine
présente ses vœux ce soir c'est toi
arabe de Jardy vous le voyez on retrouve
sur place Nicolas dandry de la rédaction
de TV 78 pouvez-vous nous rappeler déjà
Nicolas ce qu'est un établissement
public interdépartemental et ceux qui
pourraient se dire ce soir du côté
demande la coquette
alors et bien Grégory bonsoir
l'établissement public
interdépartemental c'est clairement la
coopération entre le département des
Yvelines et des Hauts-de-Seine sur
plusieurs sujets et je peux vous dire
que ici c'est une cérémonie des vœux qui
sera à cheval entre le département des
Yvelines et des hautes et ça tombe bien
nous sommes au Haras de Jardy pour une
cérémonie de vœux ou Pierre Bédié le
président du département des Yvelines et
Georges Siffredi vont faire et ben leur
discours genre si Freddy le président du
conseil départemental des hauts-de-sept
alors ça va commencer aux alentours de
19h30 ça sera suivi ensuite d'un
spectacle musical de l'Académie avec des
élèves de l'académie Jaroussky de la
scène musicale qui est actuellement à la
scène musicale et il y aura aussi
ensuite un spectre en extérieur alors il
y a des têtes d'affiches qui sont
attendues notamment du côté des
Hauts-de-Seine les joueurs du Racing 92
l'équipe de rugby du Racing 92 vous avez
100 ans d'émettre vous savez forcément
un lien avec les Yvelines aussi avec
Victor vous savez ce basketteur
phénomène qui risque d'aller aux
États-Unis l'année prochaine jouer en
NBA donc voilà ça se prépare il y a les
répétitions qui sont actuellement au
cours et donc pour revenir à votre
question l'établissement public
interdépartemental c'est la
mutualisation notamment des politiques
et de l'insertion à travers activités
qui est une agence d'insertion à la fois
yvelinoise et alto c'est quoi naise on a
aussi la politique de la voirie de
l'archéologie ou encore de l'autonomie
pour les personnes âgées vous l'avez dit
aussi sur place des personnalités
présentes les élus bien sûr des deux
départements alors on l'évoquait souvent
il y a encore quelques années ou parler
de mutualisation par les mêmes de fusion
on allait encore plus loin entre les
départements il y a quelques années et
ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est totalement
écarté ce projet de fusion ce qu'on en
parle encore
alors il me semble que dans certains
discours dans le discours de Pierre
Bédié et de Georges Siffredi le terme
fusion sera évoqué mais aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas tellement d'actualité parce
que vous le saviez vous le savez ce
projet de fusion a été lancé en 2016
c'était pour contrer cette réforme de la
métropole du Grand Paris en gros les
départements avaient peur d'être
engloutis dans une collectivité et de
voir leur disparition et c'est pour cela
que à l'époque Pierre Bédié et Patrick
devaitdjian s'était lancé dans ce projet
de fusion donc qui date de 2016 et
aujourd'hui c'est plus des
mutualisations de services des
mutualisations de politiques publiques
au cas par cas en fonction de
si c'est efficace pour chaque chacune
des collectivités et je vais vous
prendre un exemple activité qui était
une agence d'insertion yvelinoise et ben
finalement a servi de modèle au
département des Hauts-de-Seine et
finalement c'est devenu une agence inter
départementale de la politique
d'insertion et autre exemple c'est le
passe malin c'était c'est ce qui permet
de favoriser l'accès à la culture pour
les jeunes qui étaient un dispositif
altoé finalement et ben ça a basculé du
côté hibinois donc voilà finalement
c'est on échange les bons exemples les
bonnes politiques publiques les bons
exemples qui a dans les Yvelines dans
les Hauts-de-Seine et ben c'est une
mutualisation des services pour être une
collectivité plus efficace voilà où on
en est alors après tout dépendra de
l'évolution
de la réforme de la métropole du Grand
Paris mais ça fait bien longtemps qu'on
en entend plus parler ça remonte avant
le covid l'utilisation de compétences et
donc mutualisation ce soir des vœux
entre les Yvelines et les Hauts-de-Seine
ça se passe du côté de
Marnes-la-Coquette merci Nicolas dandry
et merci également à Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude au moyen technique des Fisher ça
peut être dangereux les fusions moi j'ai
été élu contre une fusion celle de
Coignières mortes
aujourd'hui on mutualise un certain
nombre de choses avec Maurepas on
travaille ensemble il y a pas de souci
et on a eu
beau la 22h30 aujourd'hui tous les
équipements municipaux sont éteints à
22h30 ce qui n'était pas toujours le cas
auparavant il n'y a plus une réunion
au-delà de 22h30 ce qui n'était pas le
cas auparavant donc là c'est les mesures
vont se poursuivre on a des mesures donc
j'allais dire factuel ce type de mesure
et puis les mesures structurelles qui
visent les bâtiments dans des
rénovations énergétiques évidemment
qu'on avait des gens engagés depuis
plusieurs années alors dans les grands
projets de l'année 2023 il y a plusieurs
projets de rénovation et de
réhabilitation d'abord celui du groupe
scolaire Bouvet en quoi ça va consister
c'est c'est une réhabilitation globale
d'un groupe scolaire c'est un groupe
scolaire qui date des années 70 75 il y
a jamais eu de réhabilitation c'est un
bâtiment donc ancien c'est un bâtiment
vétus de plus en plus vétuste
aujourd'hui il était nécessaire en effet
là de s'y attaquer c'était un une des
promesses finalement de notre projet
pour les années 2020-2026 alors c'est
d'abord une rénovation thermique il faut
pas la conçu comme cela comme une
véritable rénovation thermique avec une
isolation par l'extérieur avec une VMC
double flux avec une reprise des
huisseries là où elle n'avait pas été
déjà été reprise de façon justement à
limiter les consommations sont change
les chaudières on met des chaudières à
condensation et on devrait normalement
obtenir à peu près 30 à 35 % d'économies
par rapport de en consommation je dis
bien monsieur comme le prix monte on
fera peut-être pas des économies au
final mais on consommera moins en tous
les cas rénovation également de la
résidence autonomie des moissonneurs oui
résidence autonomie des moissonneurs
alors là aussi c'était une promesse
depuis plusieurs années en effet c'est
une résidence qui date du début des
années 80 qui est qui reste dans son jus
et il fallait effectivement refaire très
largement déjà les hollow hall d'entrée
les salles d'activité la salle de
restaurant et ensuite s'attaquer au
studio et notamment aux comment dire aux
salles de bains parce qu'on a là une
aberration pour des personnes âgées on a
une marche de de 30 cm à peu près pour
atteindre la douche donc ça c'est quand
même un véritable problème donc on
s'attaque à tout cela on va mettre des
douches à l'italienne donc un vrai vrai
travail qui va être fait sur cette
résidence et je pense on en a pour une
vingtaine de mois de travaux quand même
c'est c'est un chantier colossalle alors
un enjeu aussi énergétique important du
côté d'un autre lieu de de Coignières
inconnu c'est le théâtre le théâtre
Alphonse Daudet qui date des années 90
qui sera également rénové voilà le
théâtre la rénovation du théâtre la
rénovation thermique du théâtre doit
commencer normalement d'ici un mois ou
deux à peu près on attend les matériaux
arrivent progressivement il y a des
problèmes à l'heure actuelle pour se
fournir en matériaux c'est pas aussi
simple que cela pour les entreprises
mais les matériaux arrivent tout le
bardage va être fait la toiture va être
isolée et on installe aussi une VMC
double flux de façon à faire des
économies de l'ordre de 30% à peu près
en ce qui concerne l'énergie sur le
théâtre on aura quand même un théâtre où
il sera beaucoup plus agréable d'aller
assister à un spectacle aujourd'hui il a
été il fait chaud à mourir et il fait
froid à mourir donc là on aura je pense
quelque chose de beaucoup plus agréable
pour assister aux différents spectacles
et c'est un théâtre qui est très utilisé
à l'heure actuelle
par les Coignières et mais aussi par nos
concitoyens des villes environnantes et
les autres grands projets en 2023 quels
sont-ils déjà déjà ça c'est déjà
pas la
nationalités c'est plus de 5 millions
d'euros c'est quand même pas rien avec
aussi un axe commercial très fort à
Coignières voilà exactement c'est quand
même pas rien ensuite bien entendu on
lance la notre PLU on lance
notre PLU donc notre plan local
d'urbanisme et on lance aussi avec
Saint-Quentin qui financent une étude
sur le quartier gare et la nationale 10
justement l'idée le tan nous demande de
construire 550 logements c'est 500 à 550
logements on les construira
à proximité de la gare dans des espaces
qui sont aujourd'hui des espaces
commerciaux mais ces espaces commerciaux
sont amenés à être requalifiés et on va
dégager du foncier pour pouvoir
construire ces logements ces 500 550
logements mais comme je l'avais dit dès
le démon élection je serai pas le maire
qui va construire un deuxième poignet à
côté du premier et c'est pour cela que
j'ai tenu que dans l'étude faite par la
Communauté d'Agglomération soit prise en
compte la nationale 10 et la
requalification de la nationalité
pour l'instant il y a pas
d'enfouissement sur sur poignières trap
c'est quand même 120 millions d'euros
bon on a on a on a approché les
différentes autorités la DIRIF l'état
donc le département la région mais pour
l'instant on n'en est pas là on en est
au moins une requalification qui
permettrait de ralentir la vitesse de la
circulation sur la nationale 10 de
rétrécir les voix et donc de faciliter
la traversée parce que ça c'est un
véritable problème et peut-être au
carrefour des fontaines envisager ce qui
va se faire au carrefour de la mal c'est
à dire un passage en souterrain sur le
carrefour des fontaines de façon à bien
réunir en fait la ville parce que ça
c'est une nécessité absolue aujourd'hui
c'est de la pollution c'est du danger ne
serait-ce que traversé même au feu c'est
compliqué il y a les accidents
malheureusement le maire que je suis il
y a pas si longtemps que ça je suis
quand même allé je dirais me porter sur
un accident il y avait deux morts sur la
nationale 10 euh
entre les communes de de Coignières
c'est vraiment dans cet esprit là et
voyez qu'on travaille je dirais de façon
très mutuelle entre nos communes et
c'est vrai que c'est dans la perspective
aussi de l'évolution du quartier gare de
La Verrière les bécanes il est
nécessaire aujourd'hui
importante en fin d'année dernière
c'était le 27 novembre dernier ce drame
du jeune du jeune Gibril qui a été
assassiné après du gymnase du moulin à
vent lors d'une rixe entre bond rivale
vous étiez vous-même venu en parler ici
en visio dans notre édition et ce qui a
un travail prévu dans les quartiers
justement pour essayer d'éviter de
nouveau de tel drame bien sûr qu'un
travail prévu j'ai rencontré il y a pas
si longtemps que cela aussi le maire de
Maurepas Grégory garestier pour qu'on
puisse mettre nos équipes en synergie
pour travailler auprès auprès des jeunes
lui il va avoir des moyens
de la part du département notamment en
termes d'éducateur spécialisé moi j'ai
investi dans ce domaine là depuis des
années puisque depuis que je suis mère
on a mis on a deux on a deux deux
animateurs deux élus enfin et un
éducateur spécialisé qui travaille sur
notre quartier notamment des des Acacias
c'est évidemment pas suffisant donc j'ai
fait des demandes au département pour
aller un petit peu plus loin et on va
travailler en synergie avec Maurepas
pour nous éviter à nouveau un drame de
ce type alors travailler en synergie
c'est aussi faire un certain nombre
d'actions entre avec nos jeunes faire en
sorte qu'ils se rencontrent qu'ils se
rencontrent qu'ils puissent échanger
sans le faire à coup de marteau de
mortier d'artifice ou
avec leurs points voilà c'est ça le on a
il faut qu'on appelle évidemment cette
relation alors on sait pas trop vous
l'avez vu à cette époque là on ne sait
pas exactement pourquoi
il s'est passé cela il s'est passé ce
drame là tout ce que l'on sait c'est
qu'il y a une forme de rivalité entre
quartiers qui existent depuis des années
moi depuis que je suis à poignée depuis
2016 j'en entends parler
voilà et cette réalité elle continue
d'exister encore aujourd'hui on voyait
d'ailleurs les images auxquelles vous
aviez assisté Michael midoro et c'est
vrai que le mot qui était avancé c'était
l'apaisement quand même sur ce
rassemblement
la mer avait pris la parole à la fin de
cette marche blanche ça avait appelé à
l'apaisement tout au long de Sonic son
discours voilà on avait tous appelé à
l'apaisement le maire de Maurepas
moi-même la mère effectivement de ce
malheureux de 14 ans il faut quand même
pas oublier qu'ils sont de plus en plus
jeunes c'est c'est ça aussi un des un
des problèmes auxquels nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui que tous les
éducateurs le disent aujourd'hui nous
avons des jeunes en situation de
délinquance de plus en plus jeune 14 ans
13 ans 12 ans là le meurtrier est
présumé il a 16 ans voilà on est on est
avec une jeunesse qui est perdue à
l'heure actuelle alors juste avant de
terminer cette entretien on passe à
l'interview express
[Musique]
alors le principe Didier Fisher 5
questions nous poserons les mêmes à tous
les maires qui viendront sur ce plateau
en janvier alors une exigence des
réponses courtes certaines réponses
nécessitent juste un oui un nom un pour
ou contre donc ce sera assez simple ou
pour les autres on vous demande de
répondre à les en 20 30 secondes grand
maximum et ce qu'en 2023 Didier Fisher
vous augmenterez les impôts locaux dans
votre commune alors c'est ni oui ni non
à l'heure actuelle
non c'est pas le Joker c'est à l'heure
actuelle on n'a pas suffisamment encore
de visibilité notamment du côté des
augmentations gaz électricité moi on
m'annonçait 300% pour l'électricité 500%
pour le gaz j'attends un peu j'ai fait
travailler mes services en effet aussi
sur les projets des différents services
de la commune j'attends le retour de
tout cela pour prendre une décision avec
mon équipe donc mais je l'ai déjà dit au
coin n'est rien vu la situation dans
laquelle les collectivités aujourd'hui
se trouvent il est difficile de ne pas
augmenter les impôts s'il y a
augmentation des impôts ça sera d'une
manière modéré bien entendu mais vous
savez les impôts à Coignières sont
excessivement bas on nous envie côté
circulation certaines communes ont fait
le choix de passer à une limitation à 30
km/h ce que vous êtes pour ou contre une
telle idée moi je suis pour d'ailleurs
je l'ai fait et je l'ai fait dans mon
dans mon centre-ville aujourd'hui tout
le centre-ville de Coignières est à 30
km/h il y aura deux axes qui ne le sont
pas le boulevard des arpents restera à
50 km/h et la rue Marcel Dassault
restera à 50 km/h je pense que
aujourd'hui cela apaise sérieusement la
circulation dans la ville d'autant plus
que nous on est souvent une voie de
délestage de la nationale 10 il faut pas
l'oublier le lieu dans toutes les
cantines de France est-ce que vous
seriez pour ou contre une telle
obligation une incitation peut-être une
incitation moi une incitation forte
j'essaye au moins aussi de m'y mettre
tout au moins ce que je souhaite et ce
que nous travaillons avec notre
prestataire c'est d'avoir de la
nourriture effectivement de qualité et
de proximité nous sommes dans le local
le plus possible en quelque sorte pour
cette nourriture et faire travailler si
possible des agriculteurs des Yvelines
ou des départements avoisinants on a vu
dans les derniers mois malheureusement
des maires ou des élus qui ont été
victimes d'agression ou de menaces et ce
que vous dans l'exercice de vos
fonctions vous êtes déjà senti menacé
menacé le mot et fort en tous les cas il
m'est arrivé quand je me suis un peu
attaqué à certains trafics de drogue
notamment d'être comment dire oui menacé
menacé j'ai eu des menaces sur les
réseaux sociaux des menaces qui
sentaient la mort en quelque sorte sur
les réseaux sociaux et un soir une nuit
plus exactement 1h30 du matin j'ai été
réveillé par des tirs de mortiers
d'artifice sur mes fenêtres par exemple
voilà on essaye d'impressionner le maire
pour qu'il ne le fasse qu'il ne le fasse
pas ce qu'il doit faire c'est-à-dire
empêcher effectivement ce genre de
trafic aussi dans sa ville la dernière
question est-ce que vous êtes un maire
heureux oui oui bien sûr je suis un
maire heureux et je j'ai toujours pensé
que le mandat de mer était le plus beau
des mandats et je continue de le penser
voilà merci Didier Fischer je le
rappelle mère de la commune de Poitiers
de Coignières et également
vice-président de 50 ans en Yvelines
très bonne année 2023 dans votre commune
merci et très bonne année à vous aussi
merci merci beaucoup alors on le disait
tout à l'heure c'est le rendez-vous
mondial et incontournable des
technologies le CES de Las Vegas le
compte Hummer Electronic Show c'est
clôturer dimanche alors parmi les
entreprises françaises présentes la
start-up 50 chinoise chocolate cheap
cookies company l'accent je sais pas
s'il est il est alléché mais en tout cas
voilà c'est cette start-up 509 qui a
participé elle a pu présenter son
homesquest c'est une console de jeux en
mode escape game chocolate cheap cookies
Company a été incubé au ski cube de 2017
à 2019 on écoute le bilan de leur
participation au CES micronikola Landry
[Musique]
c'est une console de jeux qui va nous
raconter des histoires dieux dans
laquelle nous serons les héros et nous
allons devoir résoudre une série
d'énigmes pour progresser dans les
histoires et peut-être sauver le monde
et donc le mécanisme de jeu chaque
chapitre c'est un peu comme un escape
game on a une heure de jeu pendant
laquelle on va résoudre 5 à 10 énigmes
en coopération avec nos amis ou la
famille
le bilan il est très positif dans le
sens où on a fait beaucoup de rencontres
des contacts avec la presse américaine
ça c'est plutôt très bien passé et même
pas que la presse américaine puisqu'il y
avait des journalistes un peu du monde
entier qui sont présents lors du CES et
puis sur l'aspect distribution c'est la
même chose en fait c'est assez fou mais
on a eu des événements où on a pu
rencontrer des distributeurs du monde
entier aussi ça nous a permis aussi
d'avoir des gens qui viennent tester sur
notre stand on avait préparé une petite
démo pour le ces donc des retours
d'expérience on a même des gens qui
étaient parmi nos premiers clients qui
ont fait les précommandes qui sont venus
nous voir lors du CES et qui était
ravi de pouvoir avoir l'objet dans les
mains
[Musique]
on est en pleine phase
d'industrialisation alors nous allons
terminer l'industrialisation lancer la
production cet été et livré à nos
premiers clients pour Noël de cette
année
[Musique]
quand je disais tout à l'heure c'est une
nouvelle rubrique avec vous Véronique
Ithurbide vous viendrez désormais ici
tous les mardis pour nous donner
quelques nouvelles insolites du
département des Yvelines cette semaine
ce sont les animaux qui ont attiré votre
attention alors cette chronique on l'a
appelé les insolites de Véronique à
propos des animaux on va commencer par
parler des sapins de Noël invendus et
qui sont réutilisés de manière assez
originale exactement alors en lisant Le
Parisien j'ai trouvé la réponse à une
question que je ne me posais pas mais je
vous en fais part tout de même à savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on offre aux animaux du zoo
Thoiry à Noël parce que il y a pas de
raison d'accord et deuxième question
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des sapins vendus
vous imaginez ce gâchiez de sapin déjà
coupé
bien sûr alors en fait c'est sapins sont
donnés aux animaux du zoo Thoiry ce que
l'on méritait bien sûr alors les hyènes
les gorilles les Panthères les tigres
chacun y a droit qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
font leur soit en fait déjà l'idée c'est
que ce sont des épicéas donc les sapins
qui sont que plus forts donc ça leur
donne une bonne nouvelle soudeur là qui
qui leur fait vraiment plaisir à la
truffe et il joue avec qui prennent ça
pour une proie ils se frotte le dos
enfin plein de trucs et puis après ben
comme comme ce qui arrive souvent tout
passe qu'est-ce qu'on fait de ces sapins
plus personne on les broie et il servent
de compost organique qu'on met dans les
jardins du parc du zoo de Thoiry
on va continuer avec une association qui
s'occupe de de sauver des fonds aussi de
manière originale oui voilà alors j'ai
prononcé le mot broyé je vais le
prononcer malheureusement alors en fait
c'est une arboricultrice de Feucherolles
qui produit des kiwis qui est donc
Feucherolles donc la plaine de
Versailles et qui a réalisé que si elle
coupait les hautes herbes de sa prairie
elle risquait très très probablement de
de broyer excusez-moi mais c'est le mot
des défends soit chevreuil c'est plutôt
chevreuil il avait 9 Versailles où ça
peut être aussi des des fonds de biche
mais peu importe alors il faut savoir
que le fond de chevreuil il fait 2 kg à
peine et le fond de biche il fait un peu
plus 5 6 bon bref alors pourquoi est-ce
que donc c'est juste horrible et surtout
qu'après une fois déchiqueté c'est peu
bête elles sont intégrées dans les
mottes de onemote dont les meules enfin
bref dans les bottes
dans les bottes de foin et bah ça
pourrit ça ça fabrique des toxines qui
qui donnent le botulisme imaginez-vous
au pauvage qui vont manger ce foin
c'était vraiment deux deux choses
vraiment pas super alors du coup
pourquoi les biches viennent mettre leur
bébé dans ses hautes herbes parce
qu'elle les croit à l'abri savoir que
dans la forêt les sangliers sont pas ne
crachent pas sur un petit rôti de fond
donc ils se font croquer dans les forêts
donc elles les mettent là de sachant pas
bien évidemment que la fenaison a lieu
en mai avant c'était en août donc les
fans ils étaient déjà partis là c'est en
mai réchauffement climatique oblig donc
elle s'imagine qu'ils sont bien cachés
et voilà alors que faire donc cette
fameuse Leslie elle fait elle veut agir
elle s'est renseignée en France elle a
pas trouvé beaucoup de renseignements
donc elle s'est tournée vers l'Allemagne
et la Suisse il y a une association
suisse qui lui a conseillé de d'acquérir
un drone thermique alors un drone
thermique ça coûte très cher mais
l'avantage c'est que il détermine en
fait le point de chaleur c'est là où
sera donc le bébé par rapport au froid
de la prairie voilà et donc il faut un
drone thermique il faut un pilote il
faut lui payer on achète le drone après
il faut payer la formation spécifique du
pilote et après il faut des bénévoles
parce que cette cette recherche de fond
en mai se fait entre 5 et 7 le matin
parce que c'est là où il le contrat
c'est plus important entre le froid de
la prairie et le chaud du bébé donc
voilà après qu'est-ce qu'on fait on y
touche pas parce que l'odeur humaine ça
plaira pas la mer donc on met une cage
et comme ça le l'engin agricole un
repère la bête et après qu'est-ce qui se
passe et bah il faut être nombreux donc
pour se lever de 5 heures il faut aussi
que les promeneurs de chiens tiennent si
possible on laisse leur bête au mois de
mai parce que ça peut faire beaucoup de
dégâts aussi alors les kiwis de Leslie
c'est la page Facebook et l'association
des la plaine de Versailles si vous
voulez participer bénévolement
financièrement enfin être bénévole ou
faire un don voilà j'ai dit
le on va quitter les animaux et on va
passer au gourmand et au gourmets il y
en a peut-être autour de la table avec
une nouvelle adresse qui s'ouvre à
Versailles exactement qui s'est ouverte
alors ça s'appelle ça c'est ouvert il y
a quelques temps sont deux deux jeunes
hommes qui l'ont ouverts c'est un chef
et un entrepreneur Jérémy et Renaud
pardon ça s'appelle la rotissy alors la
rôtissaï c'est sous les halles du marché
du Notre-Dame à Versailles et on a des
images on a quelques images du site
internet et donc donc la rôtissaï donc
c'est vraiment à l'intérieur du de la
halle qui s'appelle le carré à la marée
vous savez il y a 4 carrés donc carré à
la marée donc dès 10h30 vous pouvez
aller vous restaurer le principe c'est
qu'il propose une quinzaine de viandes
différentes qui sont donc rôties voilà
vous choisissez votre viande c'est
qualité française enfin super qualité
géante vous choisissez votre garniture
votre sauce machin et voilà etc vous
pouvez aussi donc entre 10h30 et 18h30
vous restaurez vous êtes un peu au
milieu des gens il y a un bar avec des
tabourets ou alors des manches debout si
vous avez envie de compléter votre repas
par du fromage ou un dessert vous allez
juste la boutique juste à côté acheter
votre fromage et votre gâteau aux faces
et vous la portez là voilà c'est c'est
fait pour quoi c'est la liberté chacun
fait ce qu'il veut et après c'est aussi
un traiteur il fume leur saumon vous
pouvez leur commander n'importe quoi ils
savent faire
voilà je crois que j'ai tout dit et puis
bon on était on était là au beau jour il
y aura encore d'autres projets mais on
en reparlera ce qui est une information
qui a retenu votre attention j'ai fait
y aller pour déguster je pense
qu'on de des steaks vous avez burgers
alors vous avez des burgers
c'est 8h30
de canard de poulet enfin ça change pour
tous les jours
qui vous tient à cœur et pour lequel il
faut se dépêcher si on veut avoir sa
place exactement alors ça me tient à
cœur parce qu'en fait c'est Tim dope qui
est un jeune chanteur d'origine de il
est d'origine Rambouillet oui il est du
sudible
c'est un jeune rembolitain il est né 94
il a commencé sa carrière de musicien en
2015 son premier album est sorti en 2017
il est auteur compositeur
producteur on fait tout et bien en plus
histoire son 4e album Les Immortels
début février et il démarre en fait un
premier concert à
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse le vendredi 20
janvier à 20h30 alors pourquoi est-ce
qu'il faut y aller parce que Tim dope il
est il est doué talentueux et il est
généreux donc là il va jouer
gratuitement pour l'association le Red
Fugain l'association l'aurait être
Fugain c'est une association qui aide à
lutter contre la leucémie et autres
cancer du sang pour aussi inciter les
dons de plaquettes etc voilà et donc le
l'Amérique de Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse
prête évidemment gratuitement la salle
de l'Espace Jean Racine le Lion's Club
de la Vallée de Chevreuse s'occupe du
staff de la billetterie etc et team de
peu jouent gratuitement et l'intégralité
des recettes c'est 25 euros le billet
ira directement à l'association Laurette
Fugain donc c'est vendredi 20 janvier il
reste des places pas 50 000 mais il en
reste et franchement ça vaut le coup à
découvrir pour pour toutes les
informations merci merci à Véronique
pour cette première chronique on vous
retrouve aussi la présentation des Vy P1
sur TV
bientôt on va continuer à parler culture
vous avez parlé de culture on va
continuer dans cette émission à parler
de culture
[Musique]
et avant de parler de l'expo photo du
côté de Villepreux ce rendez-vous qui se
tient jusqu'au 15 janvier au Petit
Moulin des Vaux de Cernay avec la
compagnie de théâtre Pixum qui vous
propose un spectacle futuriste
l'histoire se déroule en 22 2023 lorsque
des archéologues tentent de lever le
voile sur les vestiges de la vie humaine
sur Terre regardez ce reportage réalisé
par Michael elmidoro et Régine ralech
vous allez pouvoir découvrir les plus
beaux artéfacts humains que nous avons
eu la chance de récupérer à droite à
gauche et au milieu imaginez le monde
dans 20 000 ans plus exactement en l'an
2023 c'est ce que tente de montrer le
temps des humains un spectacle immersif
réalisé par la compagnie Pixum
on vous emmène dans une épopée
archéologique
dans le futur en 2223 où les humains ont
disparu et l'espèce d'après les humains
font une exposition
archéologique sur les humains une
rétrospective un peu comme nous on va
dans des expos sur les dinosaures bah là
c'est une exposition nous avec des
objets de notre quotidien qui sont
détournés et avec des guides qui
expliquent aux gens à quoi pouvaient
bien servir ses objets que les humains
utilisent un voyage à travers le temps
c'est ainsi que se vit le spectacle en
déambulant dans plusieurs décors les
participants redécouvrent leur propre
monde cette manière de d'exposer comme
des vrais oeuvres des vraies choses côté
par des archéologues alors qu'en fait
c'est un bric-à-brac de bordel et du
coup c'est hyper drôle de voir ça de
manière sérieuse alors que ça allait pas
du tout elle nous a amené dans un
univers trop marrant et donc moi j'ai
adoré parce que j'aime bien les choses
de Marotte plusieurs thèmes sont évoqués
notamment celui de l'environnement un
sujet qui est cher à Pixum on a un
partenariat avec la Ressourcerie avec
qui on fait un échange
d'objets et de meubles la Ressourcerie
va nous passer des meubles de prêter des
meubles ou des objets dont on va faire
une valorisation artistique on fait pas
que parler d'écologie on pratique
directement
l'écologie qu'on aimerait voir dans le
monde à travers nos techniques de
création et de production porté par le
département des Yvelines le temps des
humains se veut accessible à tous il
nous questionne sur nos modes de
consommation avec humour un spectacle à
découvrir jusqu'au 15 janvier
un petit tour de table Véronique est-ce
que vous êtes amatrice de photos
mais en fait
on va on va on va regarder ça sur
Facebook on est entouré de photographes
mais justement on va parler de
photographie pour les amateurs entre
photographie un rendez-vous qui se tient
à Villepreux qui est proposé par
Villepreux images pixel c'est du 14 au
22 janvier à la maison à Saint-Vincent
de Paul plus d'une vingtaine de
photographes se présente leur clichés
pour cette expo photo on me disait en
début d'émission il y a Gilles fake qui
est avec nous qui est photographe
également responsable communication de
Villepreux images pixel on va voir
pendant l'entretien quelques-unes des
photographies qui seront exposées
s'afficher combien de photographes
participent à cette exposition on est
environ 25 photographes et donc on a
limité à 3-4 photos par photographe qui
représente environ 80 PLUS DE ma photo
parce que des petits formats et des
grands formats on a une très belle série
par exemple sur des singes dans nos
photographes Michel voilà et puis on a
vraiment le thème cette année était
libre puisque comme vous le savez
pendant deux ans on a été un petit peu
en somnolence avec le covid ça vous a
pas mal impacté au niveau de
l'association alors au niveau de
l'association oui parce que malgré tout
on a perdu des adhérents c'est vrai
comment on a toujours gardé ce lien
puisqu'on travaillait en visioconférence
mais parler de photos en visioconférence
vous savez quand les gens ont fait du
télétravail ils ont fait de la vision
qu'on fait en retour arrivée chez eux
refaire voilà une téléconférence sur sur
la photo c'est c'était compliqué et nous
on est un club d'échange et la passion
et puis la photo faut qu'elle soit
imprimée faut qu'elle soit vue on touche
voilà donc c'est vrai que c'est un petit
peu un petit peu tombé en sommeil mais
on redémarre si certains veulent venir
adhérer aux villes premier match pixel
bien sûr on a on les accueille avec
grand plaisir mais oui on a eu une
petite baisse de d'adhérents mais bon la
qualité est là c'est le principal alors
ça y est on les voit c'est ces photos
s'afficher alors qui justement ces
artistes qui sont exposés est-ce que on
parle d'anamateurs confirmés de
professionnels que c'est tout simplement
sont tout simplement des membres de
l'association alors au niveau du club on
se sont tous des passionnés puisque on
n'est pas une école de photographie
merci bien sûr on va apprendre aux gens
à servir à s'améliorer mais avant tout
ils se sont des photographes et ben
c'est comme dans toute comme dans toute
discipline on a des très bons on a du
Mbappe si j'ose dire on a du Griezmann
voilà pour prendre des références mais
voilà ce sont tous des passionnés
certains ont
pardon on a dû le grec aussi
bon là je no comment on dit NON NON
voilà on forme les biens sur les
photographes mais je dirais que le fait
d'être adhérent aux villes primage on se
forme s'auto forme et on s'améliore
d'aller en année à vous le savez moi ça
fait très longtemps que je fais de la
photo je prends mon exemple mais c'est
vraiment quand je suis rentré en 2007
dans dans ce club où j'ai progressé au
contact de photographe puisque en plus
nous on a un cheval de bataille c'est à
dire en étant loin c'est que le vendredi
on analyse des photos de façon anonyme
c'est-à-dire vous faites une photo d'un
auteur de d'un photographe et on lui dit
les points améliorés les points qui vont
bien ainsi de suite donc à force de
regarder ça de de d'écouter ces
critiques positives ou négatives on
s'améliore voilà donc ce sont tous des
photographes aguerris malgré tout mais
on prend vraiment tout le monde on a on
vient de recevoir encore trois nouveaux
récemment ils vont exposer et bien sûr
ils sont les bienvenus voilà toutes les
photos sont les bienvenues et comment
vous les sélectionnez justement les
photos qui qui sont montrées lors de
cette exposition alors dans un premier
temps détermine thème donc cette année
comme si on savait pas si ça allait
avoir lieu cette exposition on a fait un
thème libre donc ça veut dire que déjà
les photographes font quand même une
bibliothèque chez eux de photos ils
choisissent des clichés soit une série
pas forcément une série de
l'architecture des animaux il y en a qui
font des voyages là on est parti aussi
avec le club faire une série à la à la
défense sur l'architecture et puis s'ils
hésitent sur des sur certaines photos et
bien on les aide à faire le choix voilà
est-ce que cette année il y en a une
peut-être qui a retenu un peu plus votre
attention une préférée ou c'est une
voulez pas vous positionner
dans le club quand même prochainement
voilà non non chaque vous savez le
principal c'est que le photographe aime
sa photo et après vous aurez toujours
des gens qui ont aimé et d'autres qui
vont pas aimer c'est bon voilà non non
il y a pas vraiment de photos pour
l'instant qui qui qui sont détachés
elles valent toutes le coup comme on dit
et vous êtes plutôt photos on va dire
purement naturel retravailler peut-être
à l'ordinateur alors par rapport à moi
comme on dit je suis old school
maintenant puisque faut dire vieille
école c'est à moi j'ai appris la photo
c'est l'oeil moi j'ai un atelier qui
s'appelle l'oeil du photographe pour moi
un photographe c'est l'oeil et puis
évidemment on est obligé de passer par
du numérique on a des logiciels pour les
développer comme j plus que de les
retoucher certains retouches on a une
très belle série par exemple de Philippe
Philippe Lambert notre président qui lui
donne une touche un petit peu aussi qui
maîtrise beaucoup ses outils mais voilà
donc moi je suis plutôt alors je
m'occupe d'un studio photo aussi au sein
du club donc j'aime bien faire de la
photo de studio donc avec des modèles
mais aussi des natures mortes enfin
voilà ça j'aime bien faire ça mais bon
vous êtes d'accord
moi je ne retouche pas et c'est no
filter oui voilà voilà
est-ce que ces oeuvres pourront être
achetées oui alors donc on aura des
petites pastilles en fonction donc ça
c'est les photographes qui déterminent
le leur prix en fonction d'espace ça va
aller on va dire de de 20 € jusqu'à 120
€ 150 €. et on a toute une collection
d'anciennes photos qui ont fait des
concours qui seront pour faire plaisir
aux gens on les met à la vente je crois
que c'est 5 euros vous pouvez venir me
faire plaisir avec une photo dans une
Marie-Louise très sympa et toutes les
informations qui s'affichent de nouveau
ce qu'il y a d'autres rendez-vous prévu
dans l'année vous l'avez dit après le
covid ça reprend alors ça reprend on a
quand même comme vous le savez on a été
le premier club à créer le festival de
la photo panoramique en 2014 j'étais
venu d'ailleurs ici en parler on le
faisait tous les deux ans parce que
c'est vraiment très lourd on se pose la
question de savoir si on va le faire en
donc voilà ça c'est un projet et puis
sinon on a un projet qu'on voudrait
relancer avec justement l'atelier studio
photo c'est les villes prosiens et leurs
animaux donc on l'avait déjà fait et on
exposera on l'espère on demandera bien
sûr au merde d'exposer dans la mairie ou
les villes prosiens viennent avec alors
c'était super parce qu'ils sont venus
avec des lapins des des chats bien sûr
des chiens et on avait un très beau
perroquet enfin voilà on a eu des poules
enfin le lien social oui voilà et puis
c'est l'occasion nous de montrer nos
notre savoir-faire et puis au vile-point
de repartir avec une belle photo de avec
leur animal quoi Véronique grande
amatrice de culture vous avez pu voir
quelques clichés qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez bah ça me donne très envie et en
plus de savoir qu'il y a des c'est
vraiment à tous les prix
accessibles à tout le monde l'entrée de
l'exposition est gratuite c'est une
entrée libre et l'intérêt de cette
exposition alors c'est que les week-ends
et c'est tenu les permanences sont
tenues par des photographes donc
l'intérêt c'est que vous allez aussi en
même temps pouvoir discuter et voir
comment les photos sont prises voilà
discuter avec les avec les photographes
donc ça c'est quand même aussi une
intéressante
14 22 janvier donc 14 15 21 22 janvier à
la maison Saint-Vincent à Villepreux et
toutes les informations si on peut voir
une dernière fois l'animation s'afficher
vous avez le site internet de
l'association qui s'affiche pour avoir
toutes les informations à propos de
cette exposition merci Gilles fait merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup
elle a un petit dernier tour de table
j'ai compris que vous étiez plutôt des
gourmets autour de la table Didier
Fisher nous sommes des gourmets
bien sûr nous proposer quelque chose
à 18h voilà TV 78 propose et bien des
recettes il y a les chefs cuisiniers du
territoire qui nous donne leur secret le
but c'est de briller en cuisine avec
leur astuces alors ce soir c'est le chef
étoilé tomojiroido du restaurant le
village de Marly-le-Roi qui se prête à
l'exercice la barre est très haut mais
on va essayer de reproduire cette
recette regardez
[Musique]
bonjour je suis le chef Tomeo bienvenue
à mon restaurant Le Village à
Marly-le-Roi aujourd'hui je vous propose
un plat Kai impérial croûté en tortilla
à l'ail des os à la cuisine
[Musique]
alors
ce qui est important c'est de repos
quand on met le flore à la sortie de
four il faut vraiment minimum 5 minutes
de repos pour que la KX termine bien
bien rosé avant une vraiment belle
cuisson après pour le parfum que je l'ai
fait à l'ail des ours mais si vous
n'avez pas pourquoi pas de mettre le
persil ou du thym autre chose c'est à
vous de créer vous-même
[Musique]
et Rambouillet et dans l'après-midi pas
de pluie a priori ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle il devrait faire 10 degrés dans
la partie centrée sud des Yvelines 11
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et ce mercredi
en janvier nous fêteront les polins
voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8 merci de
votre fidélité demain vous allez
rendez-vous avec Mathilde Franco pour
une nouvelle édition belle soirée sur TV
[Musique]